good evening my name is richard meyers
m-e-y-e-r-s
and i'm a lieutenant with the las vegas
metropolitan police department
are you all ready okay as you know
this case started out as a missing
person's investigation
and unfortunately i'm here to tell you
today that is now a homicide
on may 5th two-year-old amari nicholson
was reported missing
from the emerald suites on paradise and
twain
during the course of the investigation
it became clear
that the circumstances were suspicious
we brought all of the resources of the
las vegas metropolitan police department
to this investigation including the
homicide section
as the investigation progressed it
became
very clear to us that taro rhodes was
our primary suspect
i'm here to tell you today that terrell
rhodes has been booked
for the murder of amari nicholson
there will be additional charges however
while the arrest was taking place
terrell rhodes chose to fight with
police officers
and during the course of that fight was
briefly able to retrieve an officer's
firearm
that incident was quickly de-escalated
and rhodes was transported to the clark
county detention center and booked
accordingly
i know you have questions this is an
active and ongoing investigation
we are still asking the public that if
you have any information
regarding amari nicholson's murder to
please contact crime stoppers
at 702-385-5555